[Music]
I tried to get rid of this this thing
and every Wednesday yeah
this is fulcrum levers broken lever
stuff it's an engine and it creates a
mechanical advantage but there's still a
work sealing to it okay so when he
counters with that step I'm not gonna be
able to get his leg okay it's not gonna
be able to have a knock not gonna be
able to overpower his his quad so you
want to learn some more Ikey way of
doing it which is I set up a particular
relationship between him and I the
forces involved and my internal side
where I don't do anything he does it he
does it okay so when I come here and I
step in a way that this elbow
straightens you go you go and you lost
height okay so some things that make the
elbow straight you're Ted Khan is not
inside the sweet spot so you come over
here
you go like this you think you type in
Hanko you disconnected some other things
you go backwards in your turn okay some
other things you come up you let a
vertical space for it okay you can do
that too in combination with your
shoulders which usually happens because
you're trying to shove it down see when
you lift your shoulders up we'll go back
that down watching I lift my shoulders
up you see
I create the same space as I did with my
knee back so I also and this is key why
should my hands do the same exact thing
if I'm honest my room is there's a
roller coaster on the corkscrew they're
not doing the same thing they're on the
state cockpit they can't be doing the
same thing at the same time so you see
one two
they're following the path - they're not
going like this so they're following the
path following the path one to follow
this is still on the spiral it doesn't
go I don't do it this or this
[Music]
so where do the pirouette you can't he
said to turn right and Kimmy he just
stops on this leg he comes around you
know again
don't step pirouette pirouette that's it
again okay but as you can see he
couldn't take that step and say he
should as you get wrong around that's it
you can't do it every time so when
you're not used to that right you're
used to the pirouette Academy and
someone does that which they should
because it's an opening it's a yin space
so he goes to take that boom
and you're like oh man that's you're not
gonna do it
but here's the same kind of problem he
comes around he takes the other stuff do
you see and you're here like this and
the same thing and he can't take that
second step once he takes the first step
so he should because there's he in space
there so the way that he's falling we're
gonna go a little slower
wait okay it's that this is going
forward this way this way go back do you
guys understand that this little energy
right here so he goes to take it and it
pops him again versus he goes to take it
well this is a clash you see this is
young too young
this is not like kita he goes back so
when he takes that step you see how his
arm wants to go that way that's all I'm
doing
he goes and I blend with this just keep
it going forward keep the spiral going
not here boom boom keep the spiral going
okay let's go meet up again he's pushing
right come close he's pushing I have my
pelvis in my angle I have my ground path
I have all my internals working okay so
I do keep that structure everything is
this thing right right here is see
exactly the same same same same I'm
keeping that all the same okay
even all the same you did the same and
let let him press back into that
structure you guys so when he presses
back into that structure because of the
external geometry of the technique this
centripetal centrifugal energy ride his
face to support his line of traffic
because of that he makes himself all
right and so as he falls this is me
following him down
so are you aiming a falling person not
throwing someone down so don't come here
at the end and smell victory and you're
gonna drop your weight on him oh it's
just like he he creates in space as he
starts to descend all these
[Music]
okay let's check run it hey you pushing
her down
[Music]
fourarms sake
get the elbow hand underneath your
Center not to your Lin side not to your
inside head you have to trust the spiral
you can't push down you don't jump
across the tracks just keep leaving it
[Music]
your hands doing the same thing after
you're the initial start you start doing
the same thing
[Music]
make your hands do different things
they're doing the same thing again okay
okay don't go down you got your two
steps you should try and stand up save
yourself some cami
everyone's trying not to go down get up
get up
you gave up you gave one try then you
stop you're not to stop trying so
everywhere they stand up is where you
tried to push straight down now your
hands started doing the same thing you
lost the spiral the you overpowered them
go to one finger feeling it one finger
[Music]
he went backwards on your tent con stay
in the pocket stay in the pocket bought
lost it lost the sweet spot get up get
up Leah get up you go to one finger to
show hustle you can't hustle hustle
fight for your life ookay
you're just muscling her so then lower
that that we can't struggles at the lure
I see what I was trying to do I stay the
same
he gets more tired technique it's more
violent but I don't I don't
okay so he's trying to get up
[Music]
these are being kicked out his shoulders
coming down do you guys think but I
don't change what I do okay wait for the
yen space you're going to exhaust
yourself pushes it down you say the arms
straight you're not of the sweetspot
shoulders up knees are extended arms
doing the same thing it's that real
crossover that you steer trying to
pretend as a tank on the rear cross over
the hips and the knees and the feet get
out of the lineman you don't do a rear
crossover you do a ten Kahn go your arms
her arms straight
peddle the hands then it up nope stop
Jonathan go get in the sweet spot sweet
spot your mind wavered there come on
this looks more mental to me Jonathan
right you're like wait for her you know
out here she oh yeah yeah she's stood up
now you know she's gonna stand up okay
that has nothing to do with you going
I'll let her stand up just keep your
mind on the technique go
[Music]
I'll just lead it a little more don't
smell the finish line and go you're ten
counting backwards Jonathan there's no
retreat in Aikido
there's just tactical redeployment you
got it
keep it going keep it going keep it
going keep going let him fall okay my
you kids are looking too tired come on
you gotta get some grit you gotta get
some guts
[Music]
you don't use shoving them down again
and remember hey you shouldn't be tired
at all you had a backwards tank on you
push them down come on you're backwards
ten counting your straightening your
legs your soldiers are coming up and
pushing is just leverage so let's see
roading go with Sean and do your best to
get up so wide it what's going on why
did the other one work it wasn't even
that you were strong enough was it
because this is a less strong bouquet
right what was the difference
do you know Taylor he's more supple
he's more supple more mobile so he can
get his legs underneath the technique
easier than you can get your legs under
the technique and so even with less
strength is just a more supple mobile
okay it's gonna get his base of support
and in a reinforcing position okay so
even if you can overpower the strong guy
in that in the dojo it doesn't mean that
this technique is going to be viable out
on the street okay and we're obviously
not learning the art either right
okay so let's go